don't you guys started i'm thinking what
are network resources let me by the way
uh give you a phrase a sentence which
might help you
get a sense of what all of these are
what unify them okay
network resources are any kind of
technology any kind of technology
that's accessible through a network
that's it any technology that's
accessible
through a network okay so some of these
kinds of technology that we're going to
refer to
are not specific to networks but you can
hook them up to network and they
commonly are
okay so um let's start off with hardware
someone want to shout out one example
this is the easy one by the way
say it again oh okay all right so
so seti is a particular example
oh it's a massive network isn't it and
there's plenty of technology that's
accessible through it now can we be a
bit more specific
what's the technology which is being
sort of provided
hmm be specific it's more than just
computers
like it's not like fantastic we have
millions of people's
keyboards all around the world
accessible to which part of the computer
is okay thank you so so namely um cpus
okay so what's going on here which
process are we talking about this is
i suppose both analyzing and processing
okay so the idea is i want to do a lot
of this
and being connected to a network allows
me to access that
from seti's point of view or from our
point of view make it available to
others for a useful
purpose okay all right
cpus there's one example someone give me
another one
what kinds of hardware do we usually
plug into networks
yeah printers thank you okay so
this is a different one so again
this is associated with another process
which one
displaying thank you okay now by the way
i hope you're trying to
you i hope you're seeing hopefully i'm
doing my job well and this makes sense
that you know the seven information
processes okay
we covered them last year this year
they're not like accessible topics
but the reason why we looked at them is
because they're really helpful
lens to look at information systems
because
it's a helpful way to see all the
different kinds of things that a system
can do
okay all right uh i take it
basically all of you have internet at
home um but probably not every computer
at home has its own
separate internet connection because
that would be incredibly expensive so
what piece of technology do they all
access the internet through
a modem or a router right
okay so again this thing is a node
and so is this in a network right what
process does this provide
transmitting and receiving
and by virtue of being connected to that
network right
everyone can actually benefit from it
yes
okay so we've got um analyzing
processing
displaying transmitting receiving what
kinds of other processes are we missing
we actually missed one from earlier what
would you need what kind of hardware
would you need for this
hard drives lots of them right
okay so therefore storing and retrieving
okay hmm uh we're pretty good on our
process so far we're missing
some what are we missing what's the
first process usually
collecting now um what
might you think would you connect to a
network
that could do this for you yeah michael
okay yeah thank you so
we're thinking about anything which can
actually say um
provide us with you know information
from the outside world right so let me
give you a particular example
right what does cctv mean
what does cc stand closed circuit so
what do we use these for
generally surveillance right in fact um
one of these just got knocked out
outside on pavlok just
well actually i don't know when during
the weekend it happened but a tree was
blown over and took it out as long as um
along with a few other things but anyway
what you've got is these cameras right
they're not just all sitting out there
on their own working independently
they're all connected to a network right
and so these all get fed they all get
recorded 24 hours a day into the library
service
and so they provide this process this
option this resource to the entire
network or whichever parts of it have
permission to
access this data okay
i think it's a pretty good set i think
that's a pretty good set of hardware so
if you didn't get some of those make
sure you
you get from those now with software
this is a little bit trickier who made
some progress with software can you
think of any examples
of software that's accessible just
through a network
fantastic okay so the terminal server
right
what's the idea here it's a server which
permits you guys on your
terminals to access a whole bunch of in
your case
mainly application software
okay mostly application software
but also not just application software
it gives you access to an entire
operating system which we're going to
talk about in a second that's the next
stop point
an entire operating system which gives
you permission and access to all of this
stuff
right like say all these files you can't
get to it unless you're logged into the
terminal server's particular operating
system
okay because it manages permissions and
all these kinds of other things that we
need
again we'll talk about that in a second
okay
any other kind of software that we're
missing
let me give you a clue this question
is way easier for you guys to answer
than it was
even say four or five years ago when i
started teaching this course
there's a whole new we talked about a
few times there's a whole new kind of
software which is accessible through
networks
yeah okay so um you call it cloud
software
right in the cloud you could also call
it
software as a service
that's a that's a legit acronym capital
s lowercase a lowercase a
capital s software as a service so the
idea that
you can access your email or store your
videos
or publish all kinds of content
through someone else's software okay
whether it's facebook's or youtube or
whoever's okay all of this is software
which is accessible through a network